this might not really sound like a big
story especially for our show because
it's not a show that often covers sports
but it is kind of a big story
politically the NFL has replaced papa
john's pizza with pizza hut as its
official pizza sponsor why do we care
about that I care about it more because
of how vile and disgusting Papa John's
is as a business than how vile and
disgusting their pizza is okay I don't
have anything positive to say honestly
about papa john's pizza or Pizza Hut
pizza but I have lots of negative things
to say about Papa John himself aka John
Schnatter who's the epitome of the
uninformed right winger going back to
Obamacare going back four to two years
earlier this guy from Papa John's has
been misguided and just flat-out
ignorant in terms of his political
comments and you might remember that
back during the early Obamacare days
Papa John Schneider Schnatter
I don't even know how to pronounce it he
was opposed to Obamacare because it
would have increased the cost of one
pizza by 10 cents and at the time I said
and I still believe if Papa John
Schneider said we are going to increase
the cost of our pizzas by 10 cents to
cover the cost of giving everybody
health insurance as dictated by the
Affordable Care Act I would have been
more likely to go and buy his pizza I
still wouldn't have done it because the
pizzas terrible but I would have been
slightly more likely or I guess what I
mean is I would have actually seen that
as a reason to support a business it was
it it would've been a good marketing
decision and no question of well yeah
marketing decision and I think it would
have been the right thing to do also for
his employees then it continued when the
national anthem protests got going last
year you'll remember NFL players were
peacefully protesting either by kneeling
or locking arms or being off the field
during the national anthem before NFL
football games and Papa John Schnatter
said that what the NFL should have done
is quote nipped the protests in the bud
meaning the NFL should have exercised
pressure on the speech of its employees
not exactly a free-market principal
right and Schneider ended up
apologizing and sort of walking back the
comments because of the PR damage that
it did but the damage was totally done
at that point it was total pandering he
tried to apologize by saying Papa John's
supports the rights of Americans to
protest but believes the anthem should
be honored clearly in a particular way
that's sort of trying to have it both
ways so it was a totally totally
transparent attempt to patent to pander
and now we've learned that Papa John's
and the NFL are going their separate
ways
Papa John's is saying we're just getting
less out of this because NFL ratings are
down fewer people are seeing the Papa
John's ads meaning fewer people are
going and buying Papa John's Pizza that
could be partially true but this is a
relationship that went sour right both
parties agreed to end what was an
agreement that still had three years
left and now Pizza Hut is gonna be the
official pizza sponsor now Pizza Hut is
no beauty as our president would say the
pizza itself the last time I tried it 15
years ago was absolutely horrifying but
the bigger picture is that Pizza Hut is
owned by young brands and Yum Brands is
a company that donates overwhelmingly to
Republicans about 80% of their donations
last election cycle went to Republicans
they also own Trump's favorite KFC as
well as the disturbing Taco Bell and
some other lesser-known restaurants so
I'm not going to be supporting Yum
Brands and Pizza Hut simply because they
replaced Papa John's but it's nice that
this at least has not all worked out for
Papa John because truly the guys vile
you know as a former Domino's customer
service representative or and pizza
artist yeah I'm offended I think that
the NFL made the wrong decision here
they had a chance to choose Domino's and
they went with Pizza Hut yeah but at
this you've come clean that Domino's
Pizza is terrible now right yeah I mean
I can't say that because of the
non-disclosure agreement I have you
really have 100 sure yeah that's all
getting a pension from them that can't
possibly be true a big picture don't go
to commercial pizza places visit your
local pizza shop the pizzas better more
of the money is staying local and I know
people always say David you know when
you go to a chain restaurant or a big
box store the employees are still local
and they are earning way
yeah that's true but why not apply the
same logic to a local business where
almost all the money stays local as
opposed to just the employee wage
component and some taxes right go local
I exclusively now go to local pizza
places the last time I went to Domino's
no offense Pat was I remember the date
December 30th of 1999 and the reason I
remember the date is because I became
violently ill after eating at Domino's
and at that point I swore it off I was
15 years old at the time and I've not
been back since were you healthy for the
Millenium that was a big New Year uh I
think I was feeling better by then yeah
yeah I believe so I believe it was sort
of a passing instance of distress
Domino's isn't all that all that bad
I listen I'm sure that many people go to
Domino's regularly and don't experience
what I experienced that day
congratulations to them the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad